DINOSAURIE Ganz oben! Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier. Herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid bei dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO mit Flurkenhüter und Stefan Tietze. Sehr schön, sehr schön. Vielen, vielen Dank für dieses herrliche Intro. Mensch, da fühlt man sich ja wie auf Wacken, oder was die, wo die auf Summer Breeze mit den Juicy Beats und den Riffs. Vielen Dank an Bulls Adder, Bulls Adder, Bulls Adder, eine fantastische Band wahrscheinlich, die schon im Zwischenraum zwischen Aufnahme und Veröffentlichung wahrscheinlich so bekannt ist, dass alle sagen, guckt der den Troll an, guckt der den Trottel an, dass der das nicht mal richtig aussagen kann, der sagt die Rolling Stones, was ist das, nein, ich wünsche euch natürlich alles Gute, klickt euch gerne mal da durch. Und auch hier verstanden, wenn es gut ist, kann es länger sein. Ja, nee, absolut, nee, klar, ist ja klar. Wenn es trägt. Intros müssen so lange sein, wie es trägt. Ich war neulich im Kino mal und der Film, die Laufzeit des Films waren 83 Minuten. Oh, das ist eine Aussage. Und ich fand das so geil, weil wenn du vorher weißt, der Film ist 83 Minuten lang, ist der nicht zu lang. Weil normalerweise versucht Bonny ja auch mit biegenden Brechen auf diese typischen 90 Minuten, zwei Stunden, zweieinhalb Stunden zu kommen. Also eine Zahl einfach. Nee, aber so gerade Zahlen, das sind gelernte Laufzeiten. So ein Fantasy-Epos zweieinhalb Stunden, so ein Dune. Du sagst, du musst entweder zweieinhalb oder drei Stunden machen. Du kannst nicht zwei Stunden vierzig machen, wo du sagst, ja entweder wir kürzen jetzt um zehn Minuten oder wir strecken noch um zwanzig Minuten. Nee, ich will es ein bisschen revidieren. Filme ab zwei Stunden Laufzeit können durchaus zu lang sein, weil da ging es dann einfach nur noch darum, ja, man könnte sich nicht trennen von Dingen. Du, Stefan, ich habe schon viele neunzig Minuten gesehen, die für mich sechzig Minuten zu lang waren. Genau, neunzig Minuten auch. Neunzig Minuten ist. 90 Minuten ist nämlich eine... Wogegen 83 meinst du? Genau, ich meine, 90 Minuten kann auch durchaus zu lang sein, weil da hat jemand diese Zahl hitten wollen, unbedingt auf 90 Minuten zu kommen. Bei einem Film, der 83 Minuten Laufzeit ist, sagt mir das, die Produzenten und Regisseur, Regisseurin war scheißegal, wie lange dieser Film wird. 83 Minuten ist ja kein Ziel, was du erreichen willst. Also ist der Film wahrscheinlich genauso lang, wie er sein muss. Wahrer. Keine Länge. Ich gehe ins Kino, da steht Filmlänge 26 Minuten. Dann kannst du mal gucken. Und dann kaufst du dafür 26 Euro ein Ticket. Und dann kaufst du dafür zwei Packungen Popcorn und kommst trotzdem nicht mit dem Popcorn durchs Film. Durchs Film. Kommst du einfach nicht durch. Folgende Idee. Mal so als Projekt. Also es gibt die Filmproduktion, die Crew, Drehbuchautor, Angler, alle sind da. Und dann gibt es aber die übergeordnete Situation. Sammler. Ich bin der Dämon, der im Hintergrund die Fäden zieht. Ja. Und ich hexe einen ganz einfachen Zauber, einen kleinen Hex, hex ich. Und zwar hexe ich, dass immer wenn die Kamera an ist, nimmt sie nicht auf. Und immer wenn sie aus ist, nimmt sie auf. Und es gibt ein Skript, es gibt ein gutes, abgenommenes Skript. ein komplett normaler Film, eine komplett normale Produktion, alles ist komplett normal. Nur immer, wenn du sagst, okay, Kamera läuft, dann ist die Kamera aus. Und in dem, okay, kapp, danke, wir haben's, dann geht die Kamera an. Das heißt, jede Szene endet mit dem Regisseur, der sagt und... Genau, richtig, so endet die Szene, genau, jede Szene. So, und dann Produktion, ne, Drehtage, was weiß ich, wie viele, und dann geht das Ganze in den Schnitt und da kommt dann mein perfider Plan raus. Hex Hex, der Editor merkt, was ist denn hier schief gelaufen? Wir haben ja sozusagen nur das Negativ des Films, nur das, was die Leerstellen im Leerraum. Super. Daraus macht er einen Film. Und der kommt dann in die Kinos und wir sagen aber niemandem, was los ist. Das klingt wie so ein Berlinale. Ja, Acht Stunden Monstrum. So diese Special-Runde, wo so super-arzy, unguckbare andere Filme dabei sind, wo dann so neunzehnmal irgendwie so eine Blume, die langsam wächst, ein Käfer, der sich drauf sitzt und wegfliegt und dann Florentins arzi-Negativ-Film. Und eigentlich ging es in dem Film um eine Eule, die hatte so eine alte Frau, hatte so eine Eule. In dem echten Film. In dem, der eigentlich gedreht werden sollte. Und dann ist die aber gestorben, die alte Frau, und die Verwandten wollten aber nicht diese Eule haben, weil die hatten keinen Bock auf diese Eule, die konnte nicht verärbt werden. Ist ein spezielles Haustier. Ist ein spezielles Haustier, niemand hatte so richtig Lust und die war auch so ein bisschen kauzig und niemand wusste genau was macht die aber was niemand wusste die der eule wurde nämlich sprechen beigebracht genau und sie hat das testament nicht schriftlich festgehalten sondern in der eule und okay und dann bei der testamentsverlesung und nee sorry bessere. Okay, keine guten Ideen, brainstorming.
Und nur wer sich um die Eule kümmert, hat Zugriff zum Testament, kriegt das Schliessfach, nein? Aber die verschnodderten Kinder wissen das nicht und schlagen damit quasi indirektes Erbe aus, indem sie die Eule nicht annehmen wollen. Aber die Haushälterin, die Haushälterin, ja, Martha, die sagt, ach das arme Tier, ich würde es nehmen in meine Obhut, in meine kleine bescheidene Wohnung. Ich habe ja nicht kein Geld dafür, mich darum zu kümmern, weil die fressen jeden Tag neuen Karnickel. Genau, die isst mein Kind auf, die Eule, aber trotzdem lasse ich sie bei mir und da sagt die Eule, so, das ist das einzige Strip. Irgendwann sagt die, wo sie die ganze Zeit nur Hu Hu Hu Hu macht, sagt sie irgendwann, Bankschliessfach drei, fünf, sieben.
Hat die Eule gerade gesprochen?
Gib mir noch was zu essen, dann sage ich ihr noch was Passwort.
Oder war das mein Kind, das aus ihrem Magen spricht?
So, und dann wird es eine Rom-Com, weil dann die Eule verkuppelt dann die Frau.
In Rom-Com.
Okay, vielleicht kriegen wir Genehmigung in Rom. So, und das heisst, das, was wir eigentlich als Film sehen, ist viel die Leute am Set, die mit dieser Eule hantieren. Weil die ist sehr schwierig und die flattert immer und dann das Licht und so, man weiss nie. Das heisst, das ist eigentlich der eigentliche Film. Und der Propmaster, der sich streitet mit dem Produzenten. Sag mir nicht, wie ich die Eule zu machen. Das ist mein Job.
Die Eule sind zwei Eule.
Wir haben zwei Eule.
Nein, Rüdiger, jetzt hör du mir auch mal zu. Du musst am Zett hier gar nicht sein. Ich bin Profi, okay? Ich mache das schon sehr lange lange. Und ich brauche nicht, dass du jetzt hier ankommen und mir sagst, wie ich diese Eule zu präparieren habe. Hast du eine Ahnung, was ich für Ärger kriege, wenn die Eule am Ende irgendwie sagt, dass es falsch belaufen ist? Vertrau mir doch! Wir haben vier Stunden mit Eule A, wir haben vier Stunden mit Eule B und keine Minute mehr. Du vertraust mir nicht. Ich vertrau dir schon. Du vertraust mir nicht. Und das ist dann der eigentliche Film. Das Musical? Der eigentliche Film. Es wird dann überraschenderweise dann doch ein Musical tatsächlich, weil an Sets wird viel gesungen. Ich finde die Idee super. Keine Notes, bitte mach das genau so. Ich müsste halt nur irgendwie an diesem Hex arbeiten, weil das sind ja Profis, die den Film drehen. Denen fällt ja nicht auf, dass das einfach verhext ist. Das heißt, da muss man irgendwie gucken, ob man da mit Voodoo oder ... Wie alle Ideen von dir, sehr gute Ideen von dir, wird es halt ein Rechteproblem nach sich ziehen. Richtig. Weil du kannst ja nicht die Leute filmen. Naja, die Eule schon. Die Eule hat keinen Persönlichen. Was du sehen wirst, sind ja immer noch die SchauspielerInnen am Set. Ja. Das heisst, du filmst ja eben nicht die spannenden hinter den Kulissen. Es wird gleich mal keine Doku über einen Prozess eines Filmes machen, sondern es wird eigentlich eine Doku über vor und nach der Kamera, wie die Schauspieler am Set. Viele Lichtdoubles auch, aber die Kamera filmt ja den ganzen Tag. Also die beginnt schwarz. Wie lange ist der Film? Plötzlich die Kamera... Der Film beginnt schwarz, plötzlich geht eine Klappe auf, die Kamera wird aus einer Kiste gehoben, dann werden verschiedene Objektive draufgeschraubt, erst sieht man alles nur verwaschen, dann klar, dann zu klar, dann wird das wieder ein bisschen runtergewischt.
Gott sei Dank, schraubst du ein bisschen runter.
Hin und her, dann wird es getragen, getragen, getragen, so das Leben einer Kamera.
Und der Film ist 3D auch, das wäre geil.
Ja, natürlich, der Film ist fucking 3D und dann sieht man mal so das Leben einer Kamera und Und der Film ist 3D auch, das wäre geil. Ja, natürlich, der Film ist fucking 3D
und dann sieht man mal so das Leben einer Kamera und plötzlich
wird die Kamera zum Protagonisten.
Das Lichtdubel wird
zum Protagonisten.
Es gibt so Sätze, wenn ich die lese,
und dann wurde die Kamera zum Protagonisten
und ich mir so, oh mein Gott, es hat schon einen Grund,
dass Kameras keine Protagonisten sind.
Es hat schon einen Grund, dass Kameras nicht leben.
Oh Gott, Kameras sind so was von langweilige Gestalten, die einfach nur glotzen. Einfach nur glotzen. Vor allem, die können sich ja damit abfinden, stundenlang den gleichen Fleck anzugucken. Die Kamera findet ja immer wieder Neues. Ich war auch im Konzert die Tage, mal wieder seit langer Zeit, und ich musste die ganze Zeit lachen und fand den vor allem sehr süss, einen Scheinwerfer.
Weil ich, mein Blick fällt, ich hatte keine guten Plätze.
War so ein Stehkonzert.
Du hattest drei, du hattest drei Plätze, aber die waren alle nicht gut.
Und dann stand ich natürlich wieder als grosser Mensch, ganz hinten mich hingestellt, weil ich niemandem das Konzerterlebnis versauen wollte.
Und damit habe ich es mir versaut.
Meine einzige, und dann war so eine Schleise aus kleinen, ganz kleinen Menschen. Und genau da konnte ich durchgucken und da habe ich schon einen Scheinwerfer gesehen. Und der war, und Scheinwerfer sind eigentlich sehr süss, weil Scheinwerfer, und das mag ich sehr bei so Geräten, die so komplett für andere da sind. Scheinwerfer ist so, da ist sehr viel wenig Scheinwerfer und sehr viel Fläche für andere. Genau. Wie Fernseher auch. Ja. Wenn man Fernseher so einen Kass-artigen Pixar-Film geben würde, wären süße Kreaturen, weil Fernseher haben einfach ein grosses Bild für dich. Genau, anders als zum Beispiel ein Toaster. Ein Toaster ist sehr für sich so. Ja, gib mir das Brot. Ja. Was machst du damit? Das sag ich dir nicht. Das sag ich dir nicht. Und dann wegwerfen. Das geht sich doch nicht an. Hier, Brot ist fertig. Verbrannt, schau, verbrannt egal, so, aber du, es gibt keine Connection, der Scheinwerfer ging so, ich bin komplett für dich da.
Und dann der Scheinwerfer war süss, weil er hat er, er ist ab und zu so rum und es war wie so ein grosses Auge, er konnte sich bewegen, er war moving hand, moving hand, hand, er hat so geguckt und das war irgendwie so süss, so ein aufgerissenes Auge, war so erstaunt, sich in der Halle umguckt und ab und zu angeht und das war irgendwie sweet. Den mochte ich sehr. Welche Band hat er gespielt? Tito und Tarantula. Viele kennen die durch den einzigen Hit, den sie haben, After Dark. Es ist ja der Song, der bei From Dust Till Dawn spielt, wenn Selma Hayek tanzt. Den kennst du auch, den Song. Hast du From Dust Till Dawn gesehen? Habe ich gesehen, habe jetzt das... Robert Rodriguez? Robert Rodriguez, aber ich habe jetzt das Lied nicht direkt vor Ohren. Wir können auch nicht Dinge einfach einspielen, nur weil uns niemand auffällt. Du hast gerade noch vor der Aufnahme gesagt, der Podcast ist ein rechtsfreier Raum. Ja, das habe ich gesagt, aber deswegen möchte ich trotzdem nicht, dass du das überstrapazierst. Nee, ich möchte es nur als Experiment.
Und um ganz ehrlich zu sein, die Audioqualität von deinen Laptop-Einspielungen ist auch mässig.
Also da springt jetzt auch keiner vom Stuhl auf und sagt, oh Stefan spielt wieder was von seinem Laptop ein.
Weißt du warum nicht? Weil du dir die Mühe gibst, dann noch mal diese Sounddatei da reinzustellen.
Nee, mein auch nicht, weil du ständig pausierst und wieder startest. Hast du eine Ahnung, was für ein Aufwand das ist?
Ja, okay, ich glaube, wir haben es.
Ja, wir haben alle Frau Hayek-Tanz vor Augen.
Wie ist das denn, wenn du jetzt eine Band bist?
Und ich meine, wir sind ja Realisten, oder?
Also ich weiß, Titus oder... Also wenn ich nach dem Auftritt eins sagen muss, das sind richtig Realisten. Die wissen ja, Leute, die Leute kommen wegen diesem einen Song. Wann in der Setlist spielst du den Köder? Genau das war meine Frage. Wann spielst du den? Ich wollte ab und zu mal zur Bar, geh mir was zu trinken holen und willst ja nicht an den Moment gehen, wo der einzige Song, für den wir alle da sind... Genau, der einzige Song, der nicht ausgebucht wird auf diesem Konzert, diesem Abendfilm, dem Konzert. Ja, das macht man ja. Bei Songs, die man nicht kennt, gehört es, um guten Ton zu buhen. Genau, du willst einen Song hören, dafür gehst du den ganzen Abend aufs Konzert, das ist klar. Ich fand den Song toll, ich mag auch den Angry Cockroaches Song. Cucarachas enojadas, besoffene Cockroaches, toller Song. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ob man den auch aus dem Film kennt, den kannte ich aber auch noch und dachte mir, die spielen bei mir in der Nähe, hat mir Spotify angezeigt und ich habe gedacht, hey, toll, ich gehe mal gerne aufs Konzert, die machen Musik, da kann ich prinzipiell was mit anfangen, die werden noch andere tolle Songs haben. Ich war eher ruhiger und atmosphärischer.
Aha.
Hat mir tatsächlich aber sehr gut gefallen, haben ganz doll gespielt ist eine kalifornische Band, hat in Köln gespielt bei mir um die Ecke und ich fand es toll da hinzugehen und genau meine grösste Frage war, wann spielen sie After Dark und es war der vorletzte Song oder sowas wahrscheinlich, weil sonst gehen die Leute das willst du. Es war der vorletzte Song. Dann kamen noch ein, zwei Songs, dann sind die von der Bühne, dann noch Zugabe, zwei Zugaben. Ja, und das ist so traurig. Ich bin kein Fan von Konzerten. Ich war einmal auf einem Konzert und der Sänger hatte ein gebrochenes Bein und meinte, ja, wir haben gestern in Dublin gespielt, boah war so krass, da habe ich mir das Bein gebrochen und jetzt heute in Köln, jetzt sitze ich hier. Und denkst du dir, ich wäre lieber gestern in Dublin dabei gewesen, wenn du das so sagst. Können wir sich jetzt den Arm brechen? Wenn du auf die Bühne gehst und sagst, hey, Heil Köln, ey Leute, gestern in Dublin, das war die beste Show meines Lebens. Ich bin heute ein bisschen ruhiger, weil gestern war so krass, ich bin so hungover noch. Ich bin so drauf und ehrlich gesagt, diesen Zauber werden wir nie wieder einfallen, nie wieder. Die ganze Band schüttelig. War jemand schon mal in Dublin? Weil Dublin war so amazing gestern. Keine einzige Person, wow, das war krass und ich wäre lieber heute auch noch mal in Dublin als hier. Und ich denke mir so, warum sind wir hier, was ist da los? Aber welche Band war es? Das war Glass Animals. Glass Animals. Und die machen Musik, wo man sich Beine bricht? Anscheinend, ja, ich weiß es nicht. Du wirkst nicht wie jemand, der Musik hört, wo sich jemand bei Auftritten Beine bricht. Ist das ein Kompliment? Eine Beleidigung. Nee, gar nicht. Ich muss mich werfen. Ist die Tatsache, dass ich so lange darüber nachdenken muss, eine Beleidigung meiner... Der bekannteste Song von Glass Animals. Ne, jetzt... Stefan, wir können nicht ständig Sachen einspielen. Wir können nicht ständig Sachen einspielen. Und genau das habe ich mir nämlich gedacht. Man bricht sich doch nicht bei... Bricht man denn doch kein Bein! Ja, ich weiss auch nicht, was in fucking Dublin passiert ist, weil ich nicht dabei war!
Was ist denn in Dublin passiert, dass sich Glass Animals mit ihrer atmosphärischen Lo-Fi-Popmusik in Bein bricht?
Die sind aus Glas, die dürfen sich nicht brechen, die sind so zerbrechlich.
Ich weiss auch nicht, was in diesem zauberhaften Abend in ...
Wo leer Glass Bones!
Oh, was in ... Ich wär so gern.
Und bis heute ist es ein Sehnsuchtsort, damals in Dublin, aber ich war nicht dabei. Fucking Dublin. Aber glaubst du, man kann von dem Vorfall noch lesen, in der Dubliner Allgemeinen? Der Dubliner Glocke? Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Ihr könnt gerne mal recherchieren, am Ende kommt raus, dass ich mir das komplett ausgedacht habe. Aber ich glaube, wenn man Erinnerungen nicht trügt von vor vielen Jahren, das ist schon ein paar Jahre her, aber ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass es so war, dass er sagt, ja, ich mache heute mal ein bisschen ruhiger, weil ich habe mir gestern das Bein gebrochen. Ach du Scheiße, es gibt wirklich was darüber. Was, wirklich? Ja. Joe Stewart suffered a fractured skull and broken leg and had to learn to walk, talk and read again In einem Tag? after his bike collided with a lorry in Dublin. Moment, ich dachte, wer im Auftritt. Lkw, lorry, kann ich gar nicht. Wirklich? Der hat einen Lkw, Fahrradunfall. Das heißt, es war gar kein zauberhafter Abend in Dublin, den ich hätte verpassen können? War das vor fünf Jahren?
Ich weiss nicht, ob du eine Erleichterung das sein, was... Seit fünf Jahren hänge ich da und denke mir, was muss da in Dublin passiert sein, aber anscheinend ist nur ein Fahrradfahrer in Lkw gefahren, was mir leidtut.
Die Grüße gehen raus. shortlisted band from Oxford to cancel their tour of North America and Europe. Moment, on Instagram he wrote, I'm extremely lucky, my family and friends and the doctors and nurses in Dublin are remarkable people. The band my family sat next to me in the hospital for two weeks while I couldn't speak or move. So, but get them to leave. So, aber jetzt deine ganze Story zerbricht. Ah, scheisse. Moment, er konnte zwei Wochen lang, ne, aber wo war das Krankenhaus? Vielleicht war das Krankenhaus in Köln. Nee, vielleicht war es in Köln. Die Nurses in Dublin are remarkable people. Warum betonen die das so ständig, dass es in Dublin ist? Es könnte auch in Köln sein. Als würden Sie nicht, hä?
Oder, oder, vielleicht ist es ein anderer Accident, die Band kommt wahrscheinlich aus Dublin,
richtig? Kann gut sein, ja.
Das heißt, wenn denen ein Unfall passiert, dann in Dublin.
Wenn dann in Dublin, ja. Aber wenn sie sich ein Konzert, beim Konzerten
ein Leg brechen, dann wahrscheinlich auch
vor allem, man sagt ja Break a Leg
bei Konzerten, aber gut, kann sein,
dass ich das falsch in Erinnerung habe, dass es direkt
gestern war, aber er meinte,
ich kann mich wirklich erinnern, dass er in Köln gesagt hat,
ich mache heute mal nicht so viel
Und... Bei Konzerten. Aber gut, kann sein, dass ich das falsch in Erinnerung habe, dass es direkt gestern war. Aber er meinte, ich kann mich wirklich erinnern, dass er in Köln gesagt hat, ich mache heute mal nicht so wild, ich habe mir ein Bein gebrochen. Aber da scheint mehr Zeit vergangen zu sein. Wir reden über den Drummer. Der Drummer sustains brain damage in cycling accident. Moment, das sind zwei verschiedene Leute, einer Bein, einer Kopf. Nee, nee, der hat sich, his leg was broken. Was ist denn mit dieser Band los? Glass, Glass. Also, Glass Animals, der Drummer hat sich vor fünf Jahren ein Bein gebrochen und Kopfweh zugetragen, nachhaltige Repressalien durch einen Lkw-Unfall, aber nicht beim Konzert. Du meinst den Sänger von Glass Animals. Wie heisst denn der Sänger? Das weiss ich nicht. Dave Bailey. Ich kenne mich nicht so aus mit Bands. Einmal im Leben auf einem Konzert und jetzt wird das hier auseinandergenommen. Aber habe ich so eine falsche Erinnerung? Manchmal sind Erinnerungen trügerisch, falsch und schlichtweg lustig. Oder hat er gesagt, wir machen heute mal nicht so wild, weil unser Drummond gebrochenes Bein hat. Fallen gerade alle Sachen, die ich jemals im Podcast erzählt habe, komplett auseinander? Hä, und hier steht explizit, dass du nie in einem Callcenter gearbeitet hast. Warum weiss die Dab Glocke, heil da, was gibt's denn für eine Verbindung hier? The Dublin Bell hat für dich geschlagen, du weisst, was diese Redewendung bedeutet. Oh ja, ja, ja, wenn die Dubliner Glocken läuten. Wimmeln ist es mit dem Lügen vorbei. Ist es nicht dein zweiter Roman, die Glocken in Dublin? Die Glocken in Dublin. Wie dein Erotik Ficktrip schrip-Schmuddel. Fick-Trip finde ich jetzt gemein, also das hat der Guardian ähnlich gesagt, aber ich bin erstmal froh, dass sie sie überhaupt gelesen haben. Ja, auf Deutsch. Aber Glocken in Dublin ist nach Schatten in Rom mein zweiter Roman. Es ist, es klickt schon da an. Bisschen expliziter, ist noch ein bisschen expliziter, habe ich das Gefühl. Es ist ein bisschen expliziter, aber es geht ja auch noch mehr um diesen Wunsch der Freiheit, der, genau, sie will sich freispielen, die Hauptperson, und trifft dann halt auch diese Jungsgruppe. Und die zerleben den Urlaub, zerleben den Urlaub in Dublin. Aber sie kommt ja gar nicht aus Dublin ursprünglich. Nee, nee, sie ist Touristin. Ach so, okay. Wo kommt sie ursprünglich her? Hast du es nicht gelesen? Ich konnte es noch nicht lesen. Du hast es gelesen. Nee, ich habe die Schatten.
Was wird mir darüber gesprochen?
Die Schatten in Rom habe ich gelesen, aber ich habe noch nicht die Glocken in Dublin gelesen.
Nicht die Glocken, Glocken in Dublin.
Okay, das ist aber definitiv mehr, weil sonst hieß ja Glocke in Dublin.
Das war ja mein Feedback auf seinen ersten Roman, was du dir dankenswerterweise auch angenommen hast.
Das freut mich sehr, danke Stefan.
Also Schatten in Rom ist ja die Idee, spielt er damit, weiss man nicht, ob es der Schatten oder die Schatten sind. Und dann nach dem Buchlesen kommt schon, ich finde ja schon, jetzt reden wir schon wieder darüber. Aber und dann Glocken in Rom, spielt er nicht damit, weil Glocken ist immer Plural, spielt ein bisschen mit der Zweideutigkeit, die ich ja gar nicht mag. Das betonst du aber auch mehrfach. Das Zotige. Ja, das magst du gar nicht. Und der Verlag wollte halt da auch den Artikel weglassen, den bestimmten Artikel weglassen, weil es dann klarer ist. Schatten in Rom, Glocken in Dublin. Ja, aber ich frage mich, wenn du jetzt diese sexuelle Kodatation von Glocken nicht willst, warum sind auf dem Cover zwei blanke, pralle Busen abgebildet, frage ich mich. Der Verlag hat am Ende selber mitreden wollen. Es wurden nicht so viele Bücher von Schatten in Rom verkauft. Da hattest du keine Chance, das zu aufzuhalten. Nein. Okay. Ja gut, okay. Und wenn dadurch ein paar mehr Bücher verkauft werden und Leute meine Literatur lesen, dann denke ich mir, so geht es. Eine andere Herangehensweise oder nicht? Wie gesagt, das war auch nicht meine Entscheidung. Okay, okay. Ich fand es auch, ich finde es eigentlich schön, ich gehe auch nicht hinter. Okay. Aber es ist ja primär auch ein Erotikverlag. Du wusstest, worauf du dich einlässt, das hat man ja auch im Büro relativ schnell gemerkt. Es geht um ihre sexuelle Reise von Glasgow nach Dublin. Und ja, ich finde es super spannend, wie sie die unschuldige Jugend hinter sich lässt. Zur Frau wird auch nicht gewissen. Zur Frau wird, sie kann sich nehmen, was sie will, mit allen Hindernissen, die dabei im Weg stehen. Weil sie reich ist, sie hat gerade ein Testament bekommen, hat geerbt. Exakt. Sie hat gerade und ist da mit dem Geld erstmal reisen gegangen. Die tote Mutter ist natürlich auch ein Loslösen von der Kindheit und nochmal ein neues aufbrechen in die neue Welt. Ja. Ja. Ich mag das. Es ist Stille. Mhm, aber es ist gesagt, das ist so, ich hasse das eigentlich als rhetorisches Mittel sehr, hm, weil man, wenn man sagt irgendwas und das ist vielleicht gar nicht unbedingt das, was man, meine Mutter macht das auch, nicht dieses, nicht dieses, hm.
Okay, jetzt kommen wir rein, jetzt kommen wir rein, jetzt beginnt die Sitzung.
Nee, aber so, manchmal macht sie so ein, ne, nachdem sie einen Punkt rüberbringt, den ich ganz anders sehe.
Und das ist genau das, hm.
Aber man kann da nicht mehr widersprechen, ja. Ich has das. Das M ist so ein bisschen, wir machen das Thema zu. Aber der andere will es vielleicht noch, will noch einen Finger reinhalten. Keine Ahnung, Beispiel. Ne, wir haben beide damals beschlossen, dass wir die Band nicht mehr sehen wollen. Ich habe keine Chance. Ich habe keine Chance, ich bin Schachmatt, Rücken zur Wand, Rücken zur Wand. Wir waren uns beide damals beide einig. Du willst jetzt die Karten wieder kaufen, wir haben eigentlich entschieden, wir wollen diese Band nicht mehr sehen. Und dann redest du schon weiter und ich sag, hm? Und dieses hm ist so inklusiv, man hört dem anderen nicht zu, es zieht einem so auf die Seite. Es ist so ein bisschen, ah, ist schon gut, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Es kommen nur noch Töne aus mir raus. Ich habe alle Worte gesagt, die gesagt werden müssen. Ich brauche nur einen Ton, um du bist Schachmatt. Ja, ich hasse das so. Das ist gemein. Hast du dir schon mal was gebrochen? Also so richtig, also jetzt nicht in Dublin oder generell? Ja, Schlüsselbein. Ach ja, stimmt, ich erinnere mich, das war eine intensive Phase unseres Lebens. Schlüsselbein gebrochen, immer noch so eine schlimme Narbe. Aber auch cool. Krieg viele Komplimente für die Narbe. Also so richtig coole Narbe. Vor allem die Narbe, Schlüsselbein ist ja an einem guten Ort, weil immer wenn du baden gehst, T-Shirt aussiehst, boah ist das heiß hier, du kannst die Narbe gut präsentieren. Es gibt ja viele Narben, die sich schwerer präsentieren lassen, weil letzten Endes willst du ja, dass man die Narbe sieht, oder?
Ich kriege da sehr viele Komplimente und dann ist nur immer das Problem, fragen Leute, was da passiert, und dann sage ich, er schlüsselt beim Bruch, weil ich mit dem E-Scooter hingeschlagen bin. Das ist dann halt nicht mehr so schön.
Aber kann man... Bei Glocken in Dublin, das ist wirklich nur ein Zufall, und das ist ja jetzt auch einer der Jungs, mit der sie dann das hat, die Protagonistin Julie, hat auch eine Schlüsselbeinnarbe. Ja, die spielt ja eine grosse Rolle in der ersten von vielen Sexszenen. Ja, ich möchte nur wirklich immer dann diese Vergleiche, ach der Autor hat das auch und so. Ja klar, es ist natürlich, danke, dass du es zitierst, also das doch ein bisschen reingelesene dann doch schon. Ja, aber das ist alles auf dem Klappentext leider, sehr, sehr klein gedruckt. Aber es ist ja schon interessant, weil die Narbe ist ja nicht nur eine körperliche Narbe bei ihm, ne? Natürlich nicht. Also das ist ja repräsentiert und ihre erotische Anziehung der Narbe gegenüber ist natürlich auch eine Anziehung der inneren Kaputtheit und natürlich dieses Wrack, das sie da irgendwie erlebt, was natürlich für sie auch ein Reiz ausbietet. Das ist ein bisschen ein Spiegel in der Vergangenheit. Haha, da war sie da, das ist so, ich hasse das so, das sagt so viele bei Menschen aus, der das macht, ich finde das so schlimm. Wenn der andere spricht schon, hm, man ist noch bei sich, man ist noch so sehr bei sich, das nervt mich glaube ich am meisten darüber. Du bist noch gar nicht darüber, was ich gerade sage. Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass du was sagen könntest, das mich interessiert. Ja, siehste. Aber will sie ihn reparieren letzten Endes oder warum macht sie das? Nein, das finde ich albern, das finde ich ein Klischee, das habe ich schon ein paar Mal gesehen. Das ist eine Trope, die wurde schon zu häufig bespielt. Nee, es geht einfach nur darum, diese Narbe ist halt immer wieder die Vergegenwärtigung, wo kommt er denn her, was war denn sein Leben davor? Und sie ist sozusagen mit diesen zwei Menschen konfrontiert. Es ist nicht nur eine Person, sondern diese Narbe sagt, ah, es war auch mal ein anderer. Um es aufzuklären, es sind Zwillinge, einer hat die Narbe, einer nicht. Dadurch kann sie die auseinanderhalten. Klar, es spielt auch ein bisschen mit dieser körperlichen Ähnlichkeit. Wird natürlich wild auch in den Szenen, wo man dann nicht mehr weiß, wo endet mein Körper, wo beginnt der andere. Genau, sie kann sie an zwei Orten unterscheiden, an der Narbe und am Penis. Aber beim Penis, da ist es schon zu weit. Weil wenn das, da betrügt sie ja vielleicht gerade ihren, ich will es nicht zu viel verraten, aber es kommt zu einem Moment, wo sie erst am Penis erkennt sie den, ja genau, für sie, für ihn nicht. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist natürlich die Sprachbarriere auch, sie spricht überhaupt kein Englisch. Gar kein Englisch. Null, null, gar nicht. Okay, sagt sie oft. Ja, ja, okay. Superb, superb. Nee, also ja, ich hatte viel Spaß beim Schreiben. Das merkt man aber auch. Richtig viel Spaß. Kann es sein, dass du ein paar Mal eingeschlafen bist beim Schreiben? Ja. Weil manchmal enden die Kapitel wirklich auch nicht in dem Satz. Auch nicht Punkt, Punkt, Punkt oder so. Nee, das ist ein... Ist das ein Druckfehler? Das ist ein rhetorisches Mittel. In Serien macht man es ja auch manchmal aus Serien, aus Szenen hart raus. Mitten im Satz, mitten im Wort aufhören. Doch, mag ich sehr, so aus Gag. Aha, gib mal zehn Beispiele, wo in Serien mitten im Wort. Fleabag Staffel zwei, erste Szene, erste Staffel. Sie sitzen mit dem Priest am Tisch und die letzte Szene, das Ende der Szene beginnt mit einem grossen Ausfall, wird gestritten, mitten im Wort wird abgeschnitten. Neun weitere? Äh. Aber kannst du denn, also bei diesem Schlüsselbein-Ding hat der Arzt zu einem gewissen Grad mal gesagt, wir könnten die Narbe auch grösser machen. Er hat mir vorher gezeigt, in seinem Buch hat er mir gezeigt, die Narbenmodelle. Ach ja. Und ich habe mich für das Modell Hot-Stat entschieden. Und also, ich sage mal so, klar, das Schlüsselbein ist jetzt anatomisch gebunden. Ja, klar, klar. Wir haben natürlich mit medizinischen Möglichkeiten auch die Möglichkeit, diese Narbe etwas zu verschieben, sagen wir mal. Okay. Also dass sie nicht unbedingt an ihrer Schulter ist, sondern zum Beispiel im Gesicht.
Nee, nee.
Also wir müssen dann natürlich die Haut transplantieren, das müssen wir natürlich auswechseln.
Das ist ein Eingriff.
Aber die Rückmeldungen sind eher positiv.
Ich kann ihn natürlich auch einmal sehr feste ins Gesicht schlagen, wenn Sie möchten.
Das würde wahrscheinlich zu einem blauen Age führen aufgeplatzten wange das würde
natürlich könnte man natürlich aus ich bin auf ihre medizinisches institut gestossen in dieser
broschüre hier und hier steht das ist modell hot dangerous stud das wäre hier im angebot
sehen sie den hammer hier ja das wäre der hot stud hammer mit dem würde ich ihnen einmal komplett über über die Rübe zimmern und dann würden sie also hier eine Stirn, je nachdem, ich bin immer nicht ganz so präzise, eine coole, heisse Narbe, die vielleicht auch zu ihrer inneren Narbe passt. Also jeder Mensch trägt ja was mit sich um. Haben Sie auch das Buch, haben Sie auch Glocken in Dublin gelesen? Jetzt muss ich sagen, ich bin Fan. Ich muss sagen, ich bin leider Fan Ihrer Literatur.
Achso.
Sie merken es an meiner Erektion, aber ich, also. Ja, auch ich, entschuldige mich. Es ist einfach, Ihre Worte sind ja so hitzig, das ist wie, als könnte man sie anfassen. Bitte schlagen Sie mich anfassen? Ne, die Worte anfassen. Ach so, die Worte anfassen. Also das könnte man die Kurven quasi in der Hand spüren. Ich nehme mal das Modell Hot Start für die 99. Alles klar. Baba! Er macht 2000 Euro. Okay. Geht auch Paypal? Ja. Manchmal kriegt man Rabatt, wenn man sofort überweist. Ist das ein gutes Zeichen? Ich finde, das ist immer ein schlechtes Zeichen für die Webseite. Das ist ein schmieriges Zeichen. Ich finde, das ist ein schmieriges Zeichen. Ich finde, das ist ein schmieriges Zeichen. Das Wort heißt Sconto. Und dieses, ich weiss nicht, woher es kommt, es klingt ausländisch, es klingt aus dem lateinischen Ursprungs irgendwie. Das ist auch nah an Scam dran, ne? Aber ich finde das Wort täuscht darüber hinweg, dass es einfach eine shady-ass Praktik ist. Warum haben die das nicht so genannt? Warum wollen die jetzt so dringend Geld haben? Ja, ja, ja. Sconto. Was macht ihr mit dem Geld? Warum denkt ihr, ihr könnt mit dem Geld mehr machen als ich? Sconto. Die Herkunft des kaufmännischen Begriffes ist italienisch, scontare, abrechnen, abziehen. Du, sei vorsichtig, in der nächsten Folge machen wir Werbung für die. Scontare! Okay. Das Substantiv ist laut Duden sowohl maskulin als auch als Neutrum zu verstehen. Sie können als Duden, Sie können also der oder das Sconto sagen, die Mehrzahl lauter Sconti oder die Scontos. Aber was ist denn jetzt ein Skonto? Woher bekommt der Begriff Skonto? Der Begriff Skonto stammt aus dem internischen Betriebsabzug. Einfach ausgedrückt steckt Folgendes dahinter. Wenn der Kunde eine Rechnung innerhalb einer festgesetzten kurzen Frist direkt begleicht, erhält er einen Preisnachlass, in der Regel zwischen zwei bis fünf Prozent Verbrechnungsbeitrag. Moment, aber das ist ein allgemeiner Begriff, den es früher im alten venedig schon gar sie waren sie wollen sie haben es kann doch ich zahle morgen morgen morgen morgen ist er zwei oder fünf prozent wunderbar kann ich verstehen du warst in venedig ich war in venedig ja herrlich ich habe das auf instagram verfolgt ich war kurz da ganz kurz da ein Freund hat hat in der Nähe eine Vorlesung gehalten. Ganz cleverer Kerl. Und da war er in Pardowa. Ich wollte eigentlich nicht nach Venedig, aber er hat gesagt, man sollte vielleicht schon einmal im Leben da mal hin, sich das mal angucken, ist ja ein schönes Kunstwerk. Venedig, kannst du skippen. Kannst du skippen. Aber er war in der Nähe und er hat dann gesagt, warum wir ein paar Tage dranhängen und dann haben wir ihn besucht und wir hatten eine schöne Zeit in Venedig. Aber es ist nicht so unbedingt meine Stadt. Bisschen touristisch überlaufen, klar, ist ja wahnsinnig schön. Und lustigerweise haben sie eine Woche, nachdem wir da waren, ging ja auch rum, haben sie beschlossen, ab jetzt für Tagestouristen fünf Euro Eintritt zu nehmen. Zur Stadt? Genau. Also wie Disney World, es ist quasi ein Park. Weil Venedig ist Wellkulturerbe und ihnen wird der Wellkulturerbe-Titel aberkannt, wenn sie weiterhin so viele Touristen empfangen. Also war deren Idee, oh, wir schrecken Touristen ab, indem wir für Tagestouristen ein Eintrittsgeld nehmen. Und nach einer Woche haben sie siebenhunderttausend Euro eingenommen. Ich glaube, nach einer Woche jetzt inzwischen schon über eine Million Euro haben die eingenommen. Und zero Leute weniger. Und das ist ja so spannend, weil du merkst als Stadt, wie lange gibt es Venedig schon. 2006 glaube ich aufgemacht oder so. Genau, 2006 gegründet, irgendwann gebaut ist, 2007 dann irgendwann eröffnet, Soft Opening. Aber dir gehen halt hunderte Jahre fünf Euro im Monat. Das ist schon krass, rückblickend. Am Tag durch die Lappen. 700.000 Euro in der Woche. Wahnsinn. Vor allem, du musst ja da mit einem teuren Schiff hin, also mit einem Schiff hinfahren, wo du was für die Fahrt zahlst. Und dann bist du ja vor Ort und sagst nicht, jetzt nehmen wir wieder um. Das kostet fünf Euro. Das kostet fünf Euro, so machst du ja nicht. Nee, das macht niemand. Ich war relativ häufig in Venedig tatsächlich, weil ich war früher, Sommerurlaub war immer Italien. Si. Und dann waren wir da so an verschiedenen Inseln und dann gab es da die Möglichkeiten, so einen Tag macht man so einen Ausflugtag und dann gab es immer rotierend jedes Jahr eine von drei Inseln jedes Jahr. Und die Inseln waren Murano, natürlich das Glasbläserinsel, bekannt für das besondere Murano-Glas natürlich. Dann gab's Burano, bekannt für seine kleinen Stickdeckchen, und dann gab's Venedig. Also immer im Wechsel Murano, Burano, Venedig. Und du konntest immer schon im Vorhinein planen, ah, wo fahren wir dieses Jahr hin? Und ich muss sagen, Murano hat mir am besten gefallen. Wirklich? Weil du das coole Glasblasen, Glasblasen ist ja für so ein Kind einfach Magie.
Und da gab es dann halt auch.
Oder boring as fuck.
Ja, zwischendrin.
Und dann gab es natürlich auch so ein Bart Simpson aus Glas oder so.
Ah, okay, der holt dich dann ab.
Die holen das natürlich auch ab, die sind nicht doof.
Ja.
So, und dann konntest du das angucken und dann wie wir es geschmolzen haben.
Ich fand das interessant, ich fand das cool.
Sand wird verbrannt. Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt. Das habe ich da den ganzen Tag gehört. Und dann Burano war immer so ein Luftholen, weil jetzt als Kind sind so kleine Sticktücher. Wenn man Burano googelt, sieht man bunte Häuser und einen Fluss. Wenn man Burano googelt, sieht man genau das gleiche, aber andere, leicht andere Häuser in anderen Farben. Ich will jetzt nicht so gemein sein und es Burano nennen, aber schon. Nennen wir es nicht, gar nicht. Okay. Und Venedig war dann so ein bisschen der Glamour, so, oh, Weltkultur, aber gross, Eis essen, Eis essen, dann die ganzen Tauben, die das Eis essen und dann... Aperol es Blitz! Aperol es Blitz! Das war natürlich fantastisch und deswegen immer diese Rotation ist mir in Erinnerung geblieben. Ja, okay. Und ich muss sagen, mir hat es nicht unbedingt so gefallen, weil die Leute da wirklich teilweise unangenehme Touris bringen ja auch dann unangenehme Touri-Industrie mit, Preise zu krass, alles viel zu teuer, überall wird es abgezockt. Warst du in der Gondel? Nee. Du musst ja in der Gondel sein. Das war auch zu gelerntes Tourileben. Nee, ich fand es nur, das war wirklich ein cooler Moment, wo man von Google Maps geleitet wurde durch die Stadt. Und die Google Maps nicht gut damit klarkommt, dass man viele Wege einfach nicht zurücklegen kann, weil irgendwann Fluss im Weg ist, Kaval im Weg ist. Und dann musste man dann mit einem Schiff fahren, das war dann sehr schön. Da musste man so einen Schiffbus nehmen, da fanden einfach Busse durch die Stadt, als wären es, als wären es Busse, also wenn es so Busschiffe. Und da steht aber auf jedem Bus trotzdem mit so einer langen Stange drauf, einfach nur damit so ein bisschen das Gefühl erhalten bleibt. Genau, und singt. Jetzt ähm. Nächster Halt! Eisdiele! Und jetzt, sag mal, hat dich denn dieser Städtetrip auch literarisch inspiriert, würdest du sagen? Also, ich will gar nicht Foreschadowing betreiben. Nee, du hast fertig, vielleicht. Dein künstlerischer Prozess ist ja ein Mysterium noch für alle Kritiker und Beobachter. Nee, aber ich habe mich jetzt tatsächlich an den dritten Teil gesetzt. Ach, Ach wirklich? Diese Protagonistin Julie, die lässt mich noch nicht so richtig los. Hat man gemerkt auch, ja, dass da noch was auszuerzählen ist. Ihre erotische Reise hat mich noch nicht so ganz losgelassen. Am Ende des zweiten Buchs war sie ja wirklich zu einer reifen, sexuell selbstbestimmten Frau herangewachsen. Wie geht das denn jetzt weiter? Genau, das sagt man am Ende von Teil 1 ja auch schon. Und dann passiert, was passieren musste, ohne zu beraten. Und dann das ganze, das ganze kann man den Glocken von Dublin nachlesen. Genau, und jetzt hat man Tauben in Venedig. Und Tauben in Venedig knüpft dann da an, wo die Leute, die jetzt schon den zweiten Teil gelesen haben, wissen, genau, es ist offen, ihre Reise geht weiter, sie will noch nicht nach Hause, sie hat noch Erbgeld über, sie hat sich gefunden, aber was hat sie gefunden, gefällt dir, was sie gefunden hat? Will sie das nicht wieder umtauschen? Gibt es ja auch Alternativen? Will sie es zurückgeben oder tauschen mit einem anderen, was der gefunden hat? Also und ich meine, was ist, wenn du dich selbst gefunden hast, aber dir gefällt nicht, was du gefunden hast. Genau, exakt.
Also hast du überhaupt Mitspracherecht in dem, was du findest? Kannst du dich nicht selbst neu erfinden, nachdem du dich gefunden hast? Und danke für deinen Satz, den du hinten für den Klappentext beigesteuert hast. Moment, nee, das kannst du nicht nehmen. Vielen Dank. Nee, du hast ja was eingereicht für mich als Zitat. Ach, stimmt. Ja. Also vielen Dank, du hast es gelobt. Du hast es gelobt. Ich habe dir ja damals, weil ich deinen Geburtstag vergessen habe, habe ich dir zehn Klappentext-Zitate gegeben, die du beliebig benutzen darfst. Fünf negativ, fünf positiv und jetzt... Es ist ein positiver geworden. Du hast jetzt dann doch wieder ein positiver. Genau, von daher vielen, vielen Dank auch für die negativen Vorschläge, warum auch immer man die schenken sollte zum Geburtstag. Falls ihr Autoren in eurem Bekanntenkreis habt, schenkt gerne mal Zitate. Die brauchen immer Zitate, zu jeder Zeit, vor allem wenn ihr so klingt wie ein Literaturkritiker. Also, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, aber angenommen ihr heisst genauso wie eine berühmte Persönlichkeit, ihr heisst Peter Slotterdeik, dann kann man gerne auch mal ... Wenn ihr Wittgenstein ... Also, wenn ihr Namen berühmter Intellektueller Intellektuelle habt, dann solltet ihr vielleicht ... Daraus schamlos Profit schlagen. Daraus schamlos. Und ihr solltet den Leuten in einem Umkreis dadurch helfen, indem ihr Lobesfilmen auf sie abgesenkt. Ich weiss nicht, wie das rechtlich aussieht.
Wenn du so heisst.
Du heisst ja so.
Wenn das andere verwechseln.
Ich heisse Friedrich Schiller.
Ich kann auch Friedrich Schiller heissen.
Und wenn ich sage, ein bombastischer Trip durch die Erotiklande von Venedig,
ich war so feucht wie die Kanäle, Friedrich Schiller, wenn du das schreibst.
Feuchter als die Wände.
Das macht dich sehr. Ist dein Zitat. Feuchter als die Wände. Kannst du ja machen. Aber es ist genau wie damals. Wir haben damals mit der Band mal einmal einen grösseren Auftritt gehabt, der war sehr klein, aber die Bühne war sehr groß, am Friedensplatz in Dortmund, da war so ein Public Viewing irgendwie bei der WM und wir haben auf der grössten Bühne gespielt. zu einem zeitpunkt wo kein fussballspiel war es waren 20 leute auf diesem platz maximal und am nächsten tag hat bushido da gespielt beim deutschland spiel und der ganze platz war voll mit zehntausend leuten und seitdem haben wir immer behauptet wir waren vorband von bushido was ja auch stimmt aber halt einen tag vorher ja ja ja und es haben sich nicht Bist du zwei, drei Bushido-Fans zu euch verirrt, die dann dachten, ah, jetzt geht's schon los. Niemand, ich glaube, es hat nicht viel gebracht auch, aber ich fand es immer gut, das ist dieses, wenn die Informationen stimmen, alle, es ist kein Lügen, es geht manchmal nur ums Wording. Ja, aber es geht schon darum, dass du etwas beim Zuhörenden erzeugst, was nicht richtig ist. Wenn ihr Wittgenstein heisst, sagt, das ist das beste Buch bei sich jemals. Ich hatte noch nie so einen Harten. Es ist ja je nachdem, was sie aus dem Buch mitnehmen. So kann man sich ja überlegen. Nee, ich finde das jetzt albern, weil es geht um so viel mehr als das. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Das ist eine Reise ins Innere. Haben wir nicht damals ... Ich freue mich jedenfalls über Cover-Vorschläge. Also wenn ihr ... Es gibt natürlich die Cover, die es gibt, die grossen ... Aber wenn ihr zum Beispiel bei Reddit oder so was oder da draußen bei Instagram uns das schicken wollt ... Nur wenn ihr wirklich auch professionelle ... Ich finde Alternativcover für die Dreierreihe schön. Schatten in Rom, Glocken in Dublin, Tauben in Venedig. Das darfst du aber nicht einfach so dann nehmen. Dir ist dir schon klar, dass das dann nur ... Das musst du den Leuten dann schon noch abluchsen. Du musst ihn dann abluchsen, aus der Tasche ziehen. Du musst das schon noch aus der Hand reissen. Ich würde die abziehen. Juristisch musst du denen das aus der ... Ja, aus ihren Griffeln rausdrecken. Richtig, genau. Aber das muss juristisch stabil sein. Das ist schon klar, dass da nichts falsch läuft. Wann kommt bei dir mal ein Buch? Ja, ich bin ja eher so Sachbuchautor. Du hast sehr viel Anmerkung dafür, dass von dir ja gar nichts kommt. Ja, ich arbeite ja gerade irgendwie Photovoltaik für zu Hause. Also schön nochmal irgendwie die Solarzelle aufs Dach und was gilt es da zu beachten. Da sitze ich gerade dran. Ein Benutzerhandbuch. Es ist kein Handbuch, es ist eher eine Reise. Es ist eine Bedienungsanleitung. Es gibt auch einen Protagonisten, so eine kleine Biene. Und die Biene, weil die auch so gestreift ist, wie diese Solarpaneele und so und die berät einen dann so ein bisschen so, ah, wusstest du, dass du so und so viel Strom sparen kannst? Die Biene müsste eine Million Jahre summen, um sozusagen einen Waschmaschinengang als Strom zu erzeugen. Und mit solchen Vergleichen arbeite ich da recht viel. Auch in dem Buch. Und ich als Scherz habe dir ja auch ein Klappentext-Zitat gegeben. Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie das benutzt. Es kam nicht so gut an, weil ich habe in Reminiscenza dein Zitat das gleiche hinten bei dir drauf geschrieben. Ich hätte noch nie so einen harten. Richtig, richtig. Arbeitstitel The Roof is on Fire, einfach um zu zeigen, die enorme Kraft, die man durch den Solarzellen da auf dem Dach dann auch generieren kann. Wie Feuer. Das klingt als wäre es gefährlich. Es ist ja, die Sonne besteht ja aus Feuer. Also eine Solarzelle macht ja aus Feuer Strom. Feuer sind sehr kindliche Vorstellungen, dass die Sonne ein Feuerball ist, ne? Naja, was denn sonst? Kernfusion. Ein Kernfusionskraftwerk. Ja, schon Feuer. Lava. Lava! Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, ob Feuer so präzise definiert ist, dass man sagen kann, die Sonne ist kein Feuer. Schreibt uns gerne mal, falls ihr in die Sonne schaut, falls ihr schon mal in die Sonne gestarrt habt, dann passt bitte auf, pass auf. Glaubst du, hat schon mal jemand so lange in die Sonne gestarrt, dass er was gesehen hat? Dass er nichts mehr gesehen hat, da gibt's einige. Ich glaube, man sagt uns, schaut nicht in die Sonne, weil man Angst hat, dass man da was sehen könnte. Ach so, das ist der Pin-Code, oder was? Du meinst der Pin-Code? Der Pin. Der Pin, der allgemeine MasterPIN-Code, mit dem man alles, alles knackt. Kommst du mal rein. Der Dietrich der Pins. Und warum genau steht der in der Sonne? Also dein U-Bus, nee, wie heissen die? Imbus, I-Bus. I-Bus, glaube ich. Die haben gesagt, lassen Sie den PIN irgendwo verstecken. Man kennt das ja jetzt, also ich will jetzt nicht nahe treten. Ich mache ja viele Wohnungen so, aber Wohnungschlüssel unter die Fußabstreife. Stefan, die Leute wissen ja nicht, wo du wohnst. Ich habe es unter meinem Fußabstreifer. Richtig, so. Und dann hat man sich überlegt, was ist der Fußabstreifer der Welt? Sonne. Die Sonne. Die ist immer zugänglich. Die dunkle Seite der Sonne. Die ist immer zugänglich. Und da wurde dann tatsächlich der Masterpin imprägniert, falls man es mal vergisst. Falls man nicht mehr reinkommt. Falls man nicht mehr reinkommt, kannst du ja reinstarren. Verlierst dein Augenlicht leider. Die dunkle Seite des Mondes ist die Fussmatte der Erde. Richtig. Eigentlich. In gewisser Weise, ja. Da ist es auch ein bisschen staubig. Da würde ich zuerst nachgucken, wo der Schlüssel ist. Ist die kalt dann auch? Also hat das einen physikalischen Effekt, dass die eine Seite kalt ist? Direkt der Gähner, einfach direkt der Gähner. Gedanken gerade mal angesetzt und schon gegähnt. Nein, ich kann das nicht. Ich wollte so, es war wie so ein Aufstehen von einer Couch, nochmal so ein Aufraffen, um das jetzt zu lösen. Ja, du stehst auf und dann fängt jemand ein neues Thema an und du so, ich habe jetzt meinen wuchtigen Wuchtkörper schon in Bewegung gesetzt, ich bleibe jetzt nicht stehen, ich gehe jetzt einfach weiter, aber das wird nichts. Ich glaube, die dunkle Seite des Mondes meint ja die von der Erde abgewandte Seite des Mondes, die manchmal krasser beschieden wird von der Sonne als und von den Sternenen. Und von den Sternen, ja. Ich glaube, die haben keinen Einfluss. Aber wie immer der rechtliche Hinweis, nagelt mich nicht darauf fest. Bitte, bitte, bitte, nageln Sie mich nicht darauf fest. Genau. Jesus hat das auch gesagt und dann wissen alle, wie das rechtlich ausgehen kann. Das ist Jura erstes Semester und bis heute fragt man sich, ist der eigentlich der... Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, ich fuhr kurz im Reddit und dann ging das Video los. Wow, okay, du scrollst jetzt einfach während der Aufnahme, ist das der Punkt, wo wir gerade sind? Ich wollte etwas im Reddit suchen, es tut mir sehr leid. Kam Judas eigentlich davon mit seinem Verrat oder wurde der noch erwischt? Judas kam davon, was blieb war, sein eigenes Trauma, ah, ich will meinen besten Freund verraten. Bester Freund Bekanntschaft. Ah, Jünger. Ich glaube, jemand wie Jesus kann keine echten Freunde haben. Oder also jetzt gar nicht wegen der Herzlichkeit oder so, sondern einfach du kannst ab einem gewissen Prominenzgrad zwölf Jünger. Also niemand hat zwölf Freunde. Du hast ja eine Freundeskraft, die musst du aufteilen auf die Leute, die du hast. Spannend. In gewisser Weise haben Prominente, glaube ich, dann mehr Freunde, in Anführungszeichen. Die haben dann auch mehr Freundeskraft, also mehr Energie,gie die sie verteilen anstrahlungskraft wie so eine sonne eine mächtige sonne die dann die planeten um sich scharrt und in gewisser abhängigkeit aber die sonne hat da nichts von was hat er eigentlich mit den mit den dreissig silbertalern gemacht er wollte 60 daraus so also weiss man was er daraus gemacht hat also ob er sich davon einen richtig geilen Esel gekauft hat und dann irgendwie hieß es dann so, hey Leute, habt ihr gehört, Jesus wurde verraten und alle so, was und elf Leute zu Fuß. Was habt ihr gesagt? Alle haben Sand im Gesicht. Was, wo Jesus wurde verraten? Judas, hast du dir einen neuen Esel gekauft? Was?
Ach so, das alte Ding.
Ja, ja, das hatten sie da in der Werkstatt, hab ich gesagt.
Ja, aber du hattest doch nie einen Esel, der hat doch mindestens 20 Silbertaler gekostet. Nee, nee. Weil es hieß, Jesus wurde für 30 Silbertaler verraten. Ey, was macht er heute Abend ein? Ich hab irgendwie Bock, was zu trinken oder so. Ja, was sollen wir denn trinken? Ja, Wein. Ja, wie denn ohne Jesus? denn ohne jesus ja kaufen ja das also wer auch immerhin verraten wie bitte ich hätte zehn silbertaler für dass wir uns mal anständigen wein kaufen müssen und nicht jesus plöre ja aber mit jesus haben wir es immer umsonst bekommen ja schon klar dass das jetzt ins geld geht ja aber es war wasser ich es war Wasser. Ich habe das Gefühl, es kam kein Alkohol mit rein. Es hat nach Wein geschmeckt, es hat nicht geballert. Es war so ein Leid, es war so ein Leid, Weinleid. Keine Ahnung, diese halbsüsse Scheisse, immer diese liebliche Kacke, ich kann das nicht mehr ertragen, ey. Du bist relativ schnell über die Trauer hinweggekommen, dass Jesus dann doch... Nee, aber man muss auch mal ganz ganz klar sagen, nur weil er jetzt irgendwie tot ist und so und man kann ja schon sagen, dass es nicht alles perfekt war.
Wieso, er ist nicht tot?
Ach so, nee, nee, stimmt, er ist nicht tot, nee.
Wieso, warum, hast du was anderes gehört?
Hm, nee, nee, nee, also was würden, was werden sie jetzt mit ihm machen, also das ... Naja, es ist ja erst mal Anklage und so. Ja, ja, klar, aber denk das mal zu Ende, nee. Was werden sie jetzt mit ihm machen? Naja, es ist ja erst mal Anklage. Ja, klar, aber denk das mal zu Ende. Okay, wir wissen nur, dass er verhaftet wurde. Ja, aber als König der Juden, also was machen die jetzt mit ihm? Denk mal A bis B bis C, denk mal nicht nur kurz. Okay, ja, du hast recht. Wir sollten uns wahrscheinlich schon mental darauf vorbereiten. Deswegen meine ich. Also lass doch jetzt irgendwie einfach was Wein trinken oder so und gescheiten mal. Du, ähm, ich plane gerade meinen Umzug. Kann ich mir da deinen Esel leihen? Weil das ja jetzt, das ist halt, ich habe halt echt eine Menge Zeug, die ganzen Palmzweige und so und ich muss alles bieten. Sorry. Warum, wir sind ja die Jünger, oder nicht? Ja, aber Jünger ist erstmal ein sehr loser Begriff von Freundschaft. Ich habe dir damals meine Sandalen geliehen. Ja, das war einmal, wie gesagt, das war halt sauheiss und ich hatte gar keiner dabei. Und außerdem ist halt ein guter Esel, ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie, ist halt neu. Nee, der geht ja nicht kaputt. Ist halt neu. Ja, gut. Ja. Du fährst nicht gut auf Eseln. Bitte was? Nee, das sagen viele tatsächlich, dass du nicht der beste, dass du jetzt nicht der beste Fahrerfühler bist. Ich schaue in die Gruppe und die meisten Jünger nicken tatsächlich. Leute, das muss ich jetzt hören? Ja, Petrus, du bist jetzt ehrlich, du hast viele Fähigkeiten und so. Ich habe viele Feinde in der Gruppe, habe ich das Gefühl. Aber Feinde, was deinen Eselfahrstil angeht, ja.
Na ja, mein Gott, ich mag es ja ein bisschen schneller.
Unkonzentriert.
Nee, der Esel guckt ja nach vorne, da muss ja ich nicht nach vorne gucken.
Du redest die ganze Zeit.
Der Esel guckt nach vorne, ich gucke nach hinten, dann ist alles abgesichert.
Hä? Das ist doch klar.
Du steuerst oft irgendwie komisch und gehst keine guten Wege und rampelst in uns rein.
Scheiße, ihr seid echt Schweine, muss ich echt mal sagen. Ihr seid echt assi einfach. Meine Frage wäre nur jetzt, der Stammtisch ist ja jetzt immer noch eingetragen, der Jew fix, für jede Woche. Jetzt wird Jesus nicht mehr, Jesus hat uns ja auf eine gewisse Art zusammengehalten. Ja, genau, aber wenn er dann gekreuzigt wird oder so, äh, et al, wir alle waren ja primär durch Jesus verbunden, deswegen wäre meine Frage jetzt irgendwie... Ja, wir sind ja auch so Kumpel, oder? Ja, Jünger, Jünger. Aber Jünger, das ist ja... Also mir bedeutet das schon viel. Jünger ist ja auch, man trifft sich auch mal privat, oder nicht, oder? Ja, aber wir sind Jesuses Jünger, Jesu Jünger, Jesus des, Jesus des Christus des Kinder.
Da brauchen wir jetzt dringend ein neues Wort, deswegen machen wir den Jurfix her zum Beispiel. Aber jede Woche ist halt halt jetzt schon viel. Ja, okay. Also weil, wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt auch nicht mehr so viel zu sagen, weil Jesus hat oft irgendwie den Tisch und die Gruppe so zusammengehalten. Ich finde auch unser aktuelles Symbol, irgendwie dieser, dieser
riesige Schweif und dieses viel zu detaillierte kleine Teil, da brauchen wir auch mal was Neues oder so. Meinst du nicht, dass wir für uns irgendwie dieser Fisch mit dem Schweif oder mit den Zacken, wo irgendwie jeder seine Ideen mit reinbringen konnte? Ich meine, niemand weiss, was es sein soll. Demokratie ist geil, klar, aber so manchmal so künstlerisch, dann kommt da irgendwie Quatsch mal raus. Wir brauchen dringend ein neues Symbol.
Okay, ja, vielleicht so ein J, so ein J, äh, klar, aber so manchmal so künstlerisch, dann kommt da irgendwie Quatsch bei raus. Wir brauchen dringend ein neues Symbol. Okay, ja, vielleicht so ein J, J, Judas oder so, oder so, Jesus auch ja. Ja, wie, Judas oder Jesus? Du bist jetzt nicht der, ich wäre schon der nächste Anführer. Das war schon der Plan, also jetzt wo Jesus nicht mehr da ist, dann ...
Das hat er uns aber nicht gesagt.
Ach so, was hat er euch gesagt?
Uns hat er gesagt, dass der Heilige Geist und dass wir das weiterbringen.
Das ist ein Arschloch.
Wie bitte?
Hm? Nee, ist einfach ...
Okay, ähm ...
Er verraten, er verraten soll.
Was?
Du hast ja relativ deutlich gesagt, ich hätte ihn eher verraten sollen. Judas, komm. Komm, du hast ihn. Ich bin geärgert. Na gut, du wirst wahrscheinlich damit durchkommen. Ja? Ja. Ich habe Jesus verraten. Ich habe Jesus verraten. Okay. Mit 30 Silberstücke, weil es ein Arschloch war, der irgendwann einfach nur noch selber besessen war von seiner Macht.
Er hat seine Zaubertricks bei allen gemacht und so.
Fanatismus nennt man das.
Religiöser Fanatismus.
Ah, Jesus, da ist er wieder.
Oh, Leute, ey, ihr glaubt nicht, was passiert ist.
Ich wurde plötzlich verhaftet, aber Anklage fallen gelassen.
Freispruch.
Naja, für heute Abend.
Ich dachte, drei Fässer Wasser vielleicht, oder, Judas?
Was?
Ja, kam einfach davon, ne? Curb your Fanatism. Ich wollte nur gerade im Podcast-Ufo-Reddit Equivalent Dirt widerloben für dieses absolut fantastische Pufo-Connect-Dätsel. Denn er macht ab und zu von unserer Lieblingsquiz-Sendung Only Connect, wo man vier seemlinge random Clues verbinden benutze einfach die englische Formulierung, weil es einfacher ist, um dann eine Connection dazu zu erraten. Und macht es sehr, sehr schwer und eine der härteste Quiz der Welt. Und das macht er bei uns über Podcast-Hofo-Konnenten. Und in Runde zwei dieses Quizes muss man immer den vierten Begriff erraten. Man kriegt erst den ersten von der vierer Reihe, dann kann man noch den zweiten und dritten der vierer Reihe dazubekommen und dann muss man den vierten bestimmen. Genau, das erste Wort ist dieser Sequenz ist Ruheabteil. Können gerne zu Hause mitraten, bitte. Ruheabteil. Nächster. Nächster, bitte. Nächster, bitte. Zu. Wie bitte? Zu. Zu. Zu. Z, U. Nächster. Kle. Klein geschrieben. Morgen. Gross M. Klein Orgen. Ruheabteil zu morgen. Was ist die Sequenz? Was ist der vierte Begriff? Kommt ihr da drauf? Ich finde die Sequenz wahnsinnig toll. Sie ist genau so anspruchsvoll, wie das Quiz selber auch ist. Wenn nicht sogar in diesem Fall noch anspruchsvoller.
Schaut mal noch nicht bei Reddit, da findet ihr nämlich schon die Lösung, denn Pronunciator, Pronunciator hat es erraten, erraten.
Und ich habe es nicht erraten. Ich habe es gut angeguckt und dachte mir, ich habe keinen Plan davon.
Ich auch nicht.
Unser Ziel ist es mal selber, einmal das zu erraten.
Vor allem zu ist so knifflig, ne?
Kleingeschrieben auch. Ja, zu ist knifflig, aber könnte vielleicht sogar ein Hinweis sein, welche Art von Quelle man hier. Quelle man hier. Super, toll, wir freuen uns da auf jedes Weitere und freuen uns immer mitzuretseln. Ich schaue es ja rückwärts tatsächlich, Only Connect an, bin jetzt bei Staffel 1 angekommen und da ist ganz interessant zu sehen, was sich verändert hat im Laufe der Zeit, weil die Sendung ist sehr, sehr ähnlich geblieben, da hat sich kaum was verändert tatsächlich. Und nur eine Sache hat sich verändert, und zwar, wenn du Only Connect schaust, in Staffel drei oder vier, dann werden die Teams vorgestellt und die Moderatorin stellt dann die drei Kandidaten des jeweiligen Teams vor. In Staffel eins stellen die Kandidaten sich selbst vor. Also die sagt immer nur, ah, hier die Scrabblers und dann sagen die, my name is Tom, I work in a bank, my name is Eric and I also work in a bank, my name is Felicity and I'm a civil servant. Und das wurde rausgeschnitten, also das wurde verändert, so dass irgendwann die Moderatorin das eloquent macht und nicht mehr die vor. Hier trägt auch Funfacts vor interessant zu sehen. Das ist George Mitchell, who once climbed Mount Everest with a donkey. Genau, und dann nickt er nur so in die Kamera oder ignoriert es auch völlig. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn jemand kommt, and Susan Doyle, who once killed a man. Das will ich mir aber wünschen. Grossartig. Und das ist natürlich, du nimmst es ganz anders wahr, wenn du die erste Staffel anschaust, wenn du weisst, das wurde gestrichen, das war der weakest link der Sendung, das wurde verändern. Alles andere perfekt. Was können wir verbessern an unserer perfekten Sendung? Lass die Freaks nicht reden. Wer meint, also meine Idee. Okay, wir lassen die Freaks nicht reden. Okay, ja. Und man nimmt das.... Es ist so interessant, weil du als Zeitreisender nimmst du die Vergangenheit ja ganz anders wahr, wo du denkst, ach ja, aha, das wird sich nicht durchsetzen. Und du nimmst es sofort als super schlecht wahr, weil du denkst dir, ja klar, das würde ich auch ändern, weil du ja schon weißt, dass es geändert wird. Was total unfair ist, weil zu dem Zeitpunkt war das ja vielleicht noch. Ja, du hast einen Information Bias. Ja, genau, würde man es andersrum schauen, würde man denken, ah, okay, die stellen sich das aber vor, cool, zweite Staffel, ah, jetzt werden sie vorgestellt. Man vermisst auch viel durch Gewohnheit, also einfach, allein, die haben dann irgendwann auch so einen Shitstorm bekommen, weil sie ja irgendwann die Kategorien, die man aussuchen konnte, das ist ja bei allen anderen Sachen auf der Welt auch so, haben die irgendwann ausgetauscht in die Hieroglyphen. Und dann gab es auch so einen Shitstorm und viele Zuschriften, weil die dieses Format nicht verändern sollen. Und das kriegen wir ja auch mit. Oder bei allen anderen Sachen, die popkulturell irgendwie ein Ding sind, man wünscht sich als Mensch Konstanten. Man ist ein Gewohnheitstier, man ist sehr anpassungsfähig und man passt sich auch an und nutzt, statt man die Anpassungsfähigkeit zu nutzen, um sich auf etwas Neues einzulassen.
Nein.
Die Leute schreiben uns immer noch, ruft nochmal bei der Massagesessen an.
Eben an.
Das haben wir gemacht in Folge 1 und das ist Folge 413 und die Leute schreiben trotzdem, mach das nochmal.
Das ist einfach so dieser Reflex, du willst immer diesen Comfort Food einfach nochmal haben, verstehe ich total.
Ich mache es ja auch bei Uniconect, ich würde mich auch ärgern, wenn die plötzlich sagen können, okay, und Runde Nummer vier, jeder kriegt zehn Basketbälle und so viele Körbe wie er trifft, kriegt der Punkte. Ja, ein Hot Dog Eating Contest. Wir wollen die Freaks essen sehen. Ich will den Hot Dog Contest sehen, aber in einer anderen Sendung. Ich will, dass es eine eigene Sendung ist. Und ich will auch nicht, dass die auf einem Laufband fahren und dann den Ball werfen im richtigen Moment. Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum ihr euch immer noch wünscht, dass wir den Massagelsettel-Hotline anrufen, weil ihr konntet euch ja noch nicht daran gewöhnen, weil das war die erste Sendung. Genau, aber es muss so genial gewesen sein. Ja, es war gut, es war gut, es war ein bisschen, würden wir so nicht mehr machen. Null Erinnerung, null. Würden wir nicht mehr machen, es war ein bisschen übergriffig und diese Frau tut mir auch leid, nach wie vor. Ja. Ja. Sie ist gestorben inzwischen. Ja, die ist leider. Das hat uns dann nochmal erwischt, da ist dann der, die Nachkommen sind dann tatsächlich zu uns, haben gesagt, ja, Anruf war das Letzte, was wir je von unserer Mutter gehört haben. Da wird einem dann schon bewusst, man hat auch eine Verantwortung gegeben, seine Mitmenschen. Nimmt auch Teil am Leben von anderen Menschen. Man lebt da vor sich hin, aber man merkt nicht. Genau, macht lustige Gags, ha ha ha. Nein, Moment, ich bin auch Teil von dem Leben von anderen Menschen. Ich habe eine Wirkung auf andere Menschen. Und die ist nicht immer nur positiv. Und nach diesem, also sie hat sich nicht umgebracht oder so, es war ein Fahrradunfall. Nee, nee, es war einfach nur Zufall, dummer Zufall. Ein Fahrradunfall. Aber es war das letzte, was danach die Nachkommen von ihr gehört haben. Richtig. Und das ist, als normaler Mensch gibt es ja auch nicht so viel aufgenommene Stimme. Also wir Podcasterdödel so gibt es stundenlang. Aber als normale Privatperson ist das vielleicht das einzige Mal, dass deine Stimme aufgezeichnet wurde. Sie hatte ein Enkelkind, das war damals zwei Jahre alt, das hat sie nie aktiv sprechen hören. Wenn das älter ist, wird sie die Oma nur kennen durch diesen Prank. Durch deinen Anruf, wo du sagst, meine Enkel, was soll ich das kaufen? Nein, was soll ich das kaufen? Nein, was soll ich das kaufen? Ja, das war deine Oma. Und wer sind die anderen, wir sind die beiden Döden? Wer sind die beiden Prank-Döden? Die sind mittlerweile in Vergessenheit geraten. Auch gestorben. Die sind auch gestorben. Die sind in Vergessenheit geraten. Also der Wind der Zeit hat die weggeweht. Der eine hat dann so Romane geschrieben. Die sind ganz geil eigentlich. Die sind eigentlich, aber die da bist du noch ein bisschen zu jung für. Aber irgendwann liest du die auch, mein Junge. Es ist, wir leben alle in einem grossen Kaleidoskop und wir hängen alle zusammen und manchmal sieht man nicht alles auf einmal. Dieser inflationär benutzte Begriff des Kaleidoskops, etwas, was man nicht benutzt. Niemand weiß, was das ist. Niemand weiß, was das ist. Niemand weiß, was das ist. Niemand weiß, was das ist. Niemand weiß, was das ist. Niemand weiß, was das ist. Niemand weiß, was das ist. Niemand weiß, was das ist. Niemand weiß, was das ist. Niemand weiß, was das ist. Niemand weiß, was das ist. Niemand weiß, was das ist. Und alle tun so, als wäre Kaleidoskop, ah, okay, jetzt weiß ich sofort, was gemeint ist, weil ich schaue jeden darin an Kaleidoskop. Fickt euch! Ja, es ist ein Wort, das klingt gut, aber niemand weiss, was es ist. Es lässt sich gut als Platzhalter für alles. Dieses Ding, dieses Mandala-Dingen, was sich drehen, spiegeln und durch Formen macht. Das Wort Kaleidoskop ist selbst eine Art Kaleidoskop, wo verschiedenste Dinge ineinander laufen und Farben sich vermischen zu einem nicht ganz klaren Bild. Worthülsen, Worthülsen, Worthülsen. Ja, das war's von uns. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören beim Podcast UFO. Es geht ja nächste Woche weiter, es wird ja weitergehen. Das ist nicht das Letzte, was ihr von uns gehört habt, hoffentlich, vielleicht, also aber nicht. Ich werde über die Strasse gehen.
Schaut euch um, bitte, auf dem Fahrrad, Trakenhelm, und dann sehen wir uns auch nächste Woche wieder.
Bis dahin macht's gut, tschüss, wir heben ab, vorsichtig, Sänger, Kurt angelegt, tschüss, tschau.